it can be
beetles that come off a cactus it can be
the dried urine of a cow
little insects that grow on an oak tree
a chunk of lead that's soaked in vinegar
it's truly amazing
we're in harvard university outside the
forbes pigment collection
pigment is a very small particle of
coloured material that is mixed in with
a binding medium
the pigment gives paint its colour
the forbes pigment collection has been
brought together over several decades we
have around 2500 pigments
we have a lot of very unusual and very
rare colors
so this is i think one of the more
unusually named pigments it's called
dragon's blood um it doesn't come from
dragons it comes from rattan palms and
it gives a very bright red pigment
the unusual aspect of mummy has to do
with its source rather than the color
itself
and that comes from egyptian mummies and
it's the resin that's applied to the
outside of the bandages
i think the rarest color that we have
is actually a
an entire ball of indian yellow
and this is a pigment that is made from
the dried urine of cows that are fed
only on mango leaves
if you're looking at a work of art and
you want to understand
what
is original and what's a restoration you
will take a tiny sample of pigment and
analyze it a lot of the pigments are
actually toxic you don't want to handle
the pigments and then go out to lunch
there's a green called emerald green
that has an arsenic center to it we can
use them for
telling if something is real or not
people will say this is by a certain
artist
and we can look at the materials that
are used
and decide if those materials were
available during that artist's lifetime
if not then we have to look at who might
have painted that picture
i can't pick a personal favorite it's
like asking to pick a favorite child
no the other 2400 would feel left out